قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه رصد اطلاق ثلاثه
صواريخ من الجانب السوري
لخط وقف اطلاق النار تجاه جنوب الجولان
ونقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي ان صواريخ
اطلقت من سوريا باتجاه الجولان احدها سقط
في منطقه مفتوحه فيما نقل مراسل القناه
الرابعه عشر الاسرائيليه ان ثلاثه صواريخ
اطلقت من سوريا سقط احدها في الاردن
والثاني في سوريا والثالث في
متسار في الجولان وقالت المصادر
الاسرائيليه ان السلطات تجري تحقيقا
لمعرفه ما اذا كانت تنظيم يتبع ايران وراء
هذا ام ان فصيلا فلسطينيا هو من اطلقت الك
الصواريخ
واشارت المصادر الى ان ردا اسرائيليا
متوقعا في وقت لاحق هذه الليله ويذكر ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان كثف اعتداءاته على
سوريا منذ مطلع الشهر الحالي
ومعنا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ضعنا في صوره اخر
التفاصيل بشان هذا الموضوع
المعلومات بهذا الخصوص ان الصافرات
الانذار كانت قد دوت في مستوطنه ميتسار
وهي اكثر المستوطنه تقع في جنوبي الجولان
السوري المحتل وقريبه من منطقه خط وقف
اطلاق النار وايضا قريبه الى حد ما من
الحدود مع الاردن التي تقع في جنوبها
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه رصد عمليه اطلاق
لثلاثه قذائف صاروخيه من داخل الجانب
السوري لخط وقف اطلاق النار ان احدها قد
سقط في منطقه مفتوحه بجانب هذه المستوطنه
بينما الاخران لم يتحدث عنهما لكن
المعلومات تقول ان احدهما سقط في الجانب
السوري والاخر ربما على الحدود مع الاردن
الجيش الاسرائيلي ووفق مصادره فانه يقوم
الان في محاوله للتحقق ما اذا هذه
الصواريخ من يقف وراء اطلاقها هي مجموعه
مواليه لايران ام انه تنظيم فلسطيني موجود
في تلك المنطقه وفي الوقت ذاته اشارت الى
ان اسرائيل سترد في وقت لاحق من هذه
الليله على عمليه الاطلاق هذه يشار في هذا
السياق الى ان اسرائيل اصلا ومنذ عام 2015
وقد كثفت ذلك منذ عام 2018 تقوم بسلسله من
الاعتداءات المتتاليه في العمق السوري
يستهدف مواقع في منطقه دمشق وداخل دمشق
ومطارها وكذلك حلب وحمص وحماه وغيرها
واللاذقيه بالاضافه الى ذلك لكن اللافت
انه منذ بدايه هذا الشهر كان قد كثفت من
هجماتها وعلى مدار اربعه ليالي متتاليه
كانت تقصف اهدافا في العمق السوري الان
بعد هذا التطور الحاصل والى حد ما هو غير
مسبوق بهذا الشكل ان تطلق الصواريخ من
الجانب السوري على منطقه الجولان المحتل
الخاضع للسيطره الاسرائيليه يعتبر الاس
ذلك بانه عمل او تطور غايه في الخطوره لان
من شانه ان يظهر وكانه فتحت جبهه جديده
بالاضافه للجبهات التي نشطت خلال الايام
الماضيه بين اسرائيل والمناطق المحيطه بها
سواء كان ذلك في غزه او لبنان او الضفه
الغربيه بما فيها القدس الان هناك جنوب
الجولان السوري المحتل لكن المتوقع هو ان
تقوم
الطائرات الاسرائيليه بقصف في العمق
السوري كما كانت تفعل في كل مره شكرا
جزيلا لك من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري